joining me now is a former president of
Ukraine Petro poroshenko thank you for
joining us on this day I just wonder
first of all your thoughts a year on
from the beginning of this invasion
first of all this is not a year but nine
years of the Russian war and one year
from the full-size invasion and I am now
in the donbass on the nearest region
not very far from the front line
together with our soldiers delivering
the all support and we do maximum we can
to increase the combat possibilities for
Ukrainian armed forces and exactly that
do every single Ukrainian and I'm a much
uh pleased and appreciated for the
extremely efficient step of our Global
Partners including United Nations in
good United Kingdom with that situation
we really demonstrate that everything is
changed for this year the lesson we'll
learn is number one
well done from Ukrainian don't trust
food
number two
well I'm from Ukrainian don't be afraid
of cooking and number three
well done how to keep United to stop any
aggressor
crazy Mania could you military criminal
put him together with the troops of
Russian Federation which kill
innocent civilian victims in Ukraine and
I wish to extremely dangerous military
crime against humanity
Mr poroshenko how important is it how
crucial is it that you get uh Western
fighter jets fighter jets from from NATO
countries in the United States and so
forth
please uh we have the formula of victory
Point number one is the weapons
um the fighter jet alone cannot solve
the problem this is just stop Russian
air dominance in Ukrainian sky
it is not less important that we need
our personal career more than 1 500
pieces we need the tanks and we are very
much appreciate the United Kingdom for
the Challenger we need air defense we
need long-range missile and now as an
heir we need an ammunition
and with that situation we welcome the
Ramstein decision Angie I want to
deliver you the information we have
enough weapons to withstand uh and stop
the put in truth but we do not have a
weapons to provide effective offensive
operation and through putting away from
the Ukrainian soil with that situation
Factor number one is a weapons Factor
number two is sanction and we are very
much a pleased that the today British
government today with your prime
minister sunach make an important
decision about the sanction but sanction
should stop ability of Russia to finance
war in Ukraine Point number three is a
Justice and Justice is a Military
Tribunal against Putin for number four
is a financial support for number five
this is the pool membership Ukraine in
nature and today the young stoltenberg
invite Ukraine to Nato Summit in Vilnius
but it could be extremely important to
have the invitation from all NATO member
states for Ukraine in full membership of
India
it's interesting uh that you say they're
weapons for offensive offensive
operations against the Russians uh till
now there has been this emphasis on
operations to help you defend your
country there's it there is a a real
difference there
definitely yes we need a long-range
missile to destroy all the logistic all
the headquarters and all their British
we not talking about one single step on
the Russian territory we said that this
year we have occupied uh more than 20
percent of Ukrainian territory because
before that it was only seven percent
this year Ukraine lost 35 percent of our
economy we lost 50 percent of our
critical energy infrastructure it was 70
percent of our Iron and Steel and with
that situation but and the most
important thing we lost dozens of
thousands of innocent civilian victims
seven million of Ukrainian uh should
leave the country two and a half million
of Ukrainian children this year go to
the school abroad eight million people
additionally to the 7 million is a
internally displaced uh person and with
all these things we need as an heir and
not only in the future but now in March
or April we should organize together the
offensive operation to throw Russia away
from Ukrainian land to stop this war and
to start the process of the uh
rebuilding because we in Ukraine
fighting not only for our soil not only
for our people we protecting free
Democratic world and put in fighting not
only with Ukraine all the time now he
speaks we can fight against West
okay uh former president poroshenko
thank you very much